Người này trong vụ bỏ cơm với sinh và thủng sốt khá trôi sống nói gì?
Dên quan đến phục việc kể giống đặc liên an ngày hai mệt tử tăng chiến, người mẹ thái xong hành cạnh ra đi khó khăn
là con bệnh tật công người dưỡng được đến đáng i quần.
Chức đó, vào khoảng 20 giờ 3 mệt tử tăng chiến, người dân phát hiện một mệt phùn đứa
để cho bế sơ sinh và thủng sốt, giờ thả trôi trên sống vình, đặt qua khối tân hoa phụ bình tân, sau khi thích hiện,
một người đến những trong cơ cho bế sử đưa đến cơ sợ ý tế, có kìm ra cho bế 1,28 lưu gần, chất năng sống bị tửng, nhưng có biểu hiện vàng ra.
Những đục tinh báo, công an phụng bình tân đã tính hành xác mình, là giáo hành ngày phùn đứa có linh quan là chỉ tế hấp,
hành miệnh chiến tội, quay giả hương nghĩa, hình hương miếng, và mẹ dốt chỉ này là bản nưu, sau mới làm tội.
Bây trai được bỏ trong tùng sốt là con của chỉ tế hấp, mới được tốn ngày tội.
Lên quan để xin được một lĩnh đạo của mình, nên dân xác hương nghĩa,
hưởng hương nghen sất nhận.
Chị về hấp, lấy trồng và đánh nhập hồ cầu về giá trung phục gần, về năng đàn, hòn cảnh xa điện khá khó khăn.